Was bedroht das Überleben der Menschheit am meisten?
Ein internationaler Atomkrieg, der Klimawandel, eine künstliche Intelligenz, die ein Bewusstsein erlangt, und intelligenter wird als jeder Mensch?
All das könnte für das Leben auf der Erde katastrophal sein, aber neben all diesen spektakulären Bedrohungen die auf uns lauern, gibt es auch eine, die sich still und heimlich anbahnt.
Eine Bedrohung, die wir jeden Tag selber mit heranzüchten: multiresistente Bakterien.
Bakterien sind das kleinste, das wir noch als Leben bezeichnen und sie sind überall.
Alleine in deinem Körper befinden sich jetzt gerade circa 40 Billionen Bakterien.
Mehr, als du menschliche Körperzellen hast.
Das ist aber kein Problem, denn die meisten Bakterien sind harmlos und helfen deinem Körper sogar richtig zu funktionieren.
Es gibt aber auch Bakterien, die in deinen Körper eindringen, sich schnell vermehren und dich töten können.
Im vierzehnten Jahrhundert sorgte die Pest für 25 Millionen Tote.
Jeder dritte Mensch in Europa fiel damals dem sogenannten schwarzen Tod zum Opfer.
Bis heute stellen sogenannte Pandemien, also länder- oder sogar kontinentübergreifende Ausbreitungen  von Krankheiten eine große Gefahr für uns dar.
Vor allem, da wir Menschen heutzutage noch enger in Städten zusammenleben.
Aber, wir haben ja auch dazu gelernt.
Hygienische Gegenmaßnahmen wie zum Beispiel Händewaschen gehören inzwischen zum absoluten Standard.
Und wenn doch mal etwas passieren sollte haben wir ja Arzneimittel.
Seit 1941 das erste Mal Penizillin chemisch hergestellt werden konnte, sind wir in der Lage gefährliche Infektionskrankheiten zu behandeln.
Penizillin gehört zu den Antibiotika. Diese Arzneistoffe töten entweder Bakterienzellen ab oder sie hemmen die Vermehrung der Bakterien.
Diese Eigenschaften machen Antibiotika zu einer wahren Wunderwaffe im Kampf gegen bakterielle Infektionskrankheiten.
Sie sind so wirksam, dass sie zu den weltweit am häufigsten verschriebenen Medikamenten gehören, und mit 13% den größten Marktanteil besitzen.
Zusammen mit Impfungen haben Antibiotika die Medizin revolutioniert und Millionen von Menschenleben gerettet.
Leider können Antibiotika aber auch für Probleme sorgen.
Immer wieder entwickeln Bakterien durch Zufall Eigenschaften, die sie gegen ein oder mehrere Antibiotika resistent machen.
Diese genetischen Veränderungen sind natürlich.
Durch die Einwirkung von Antibiotika werden die empfindlichen und sensitiven Bakterien beseitigt.
Dadurch aber, haben die resistenten Bakterien nun mehr Platz für die Vermehrung.
Das Antibiotikum ist gegen diese hilflos und begünstigt eine Vermehrung und Ausbreitung der resistenten Erreger.
Das passiert, ironischerweise, häufig in Krankenhäusern, die ja besonders sauber gehalten und sogar antibakteriell behandelt werden.
Diese super reinen Konditionen sorgen dafür, dass die wenigen Bakterien die die Krankenhausbehandlung überleben, plötzlich eine Menge Nährstoffe zur Verfügung haben, und sich schnell ausbreiten können.
Besonders multiresistente Bakterien, also jene die gegen gleich mehrere Antibiotika resistent sind, können zum Problem werden.
Bisher hatten wir auch in brenzligen Situationen immer noch ein Ass im Ärmel.
Reserve-Antibiotika, wie zum beispiel Ciprofloxacin.
Ein anderes Reserve-Antibiotikum ist Collistin. Dieses wurde lange Zeit kaum verwendet, da es die Nieren angreift.
Das macht es zu einer perfekten Notlösung, falls alle Stricke reißen und normale Antibiotika nicht weiterhelfen.
Um die Wirkung von Collistin nicht zu mindern, darf es aber nur unter strengen Bedingungen und nur im Notfall eingesetzt werden.
Doch 2015 fanden Forscher Bakterien die selbst gegen dieses Reserve-Antibiotikum resistent waren.
Der Grund: In China wurde es jahrelang ins Futter von Schweinen gemischt, um dort die Verbreitung von Krankheiten zu vermeiden.
Es entwickelten sich Resistenzen, die von den Schweinen auf den Menschen übertragen wurden.
Ein solcher multiresistenter Erreger stellt ein riesiges Problem für uns dar, weil wir kaum Möglichkeiten hätten ihn aufzuhalten.
Zwar werden ständig neue Formen von Antibiotika entwickelt und auf den Markt gebracht um mit den resistenten Erregern Schritt zu halten,
aber eine Pandemie könnte in unserer heutigen globalisierten Welt innerhalb von wenigen Wochen den ganzen Globus umspannen, Millionen von Menschenleben kosten.
Was wir tun können um so eine Katastrophe zu verhindern?
Nun, nicht so viele Antibiotika verwenden.
Je häufiger wir ein Mittel einsetzen, desto mehr Erreger haben die Möglichkeit eine Resistenz zu entwickeln und desto schwächer wird dieses Mittel.
Deswegen ist es sehr wichtig, dass Antibiotika nur verschrieben werden, wenn es wirklich notwendig ist.
Diese Medikamente sind ein absolutes Wunderwerk unserer modernen Gesellschaft, und dienen nicht dazu, einem normalen Schnupfen entgegenzuwirken.
Schnupfen und auch Grippe übrigens, werden von Viren ausgelöst. Und gegen Viren sind Antibiotika sowieso absolut nutzlos.
Das ist so, als würde man einen Riss im Bildschirm des Smartphones mit einem Softwareupdate reparieren wollen.
Es ist einfach der falsche Ansatz der Behandlung.
Man könnte meinen, dass gerade Ärzte wüssten, wie gefährlich es ist, so viel Antibiotika zu verschreiben.
Aber erstaunlicherweise ist genau das Gegenteil der Fall, und viele Ärzte verschreiben auch bei Kleinigkeiten Antibiotika.
Teilweise, weil es einfach ist, und teilweise, weil die Patienten das fordern.
Wenn euer Arzt euch also das nächste mal ein Antibiotikum verschreibt, fragt lieber noch mal nach, ob das wirklich nötig ist, oder ob man nicht eine andere Behandlung ohne Antibiotikum ausprobieren könnte.
Dieses Video entstand in Kooperation mit dem Projekt Arena, das im Kontext der deutschen Antibiotikaresistenz- Strategie der Bundesregierung durchgeführt wird.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen zum Thema Antibiotika habt, dann kann ich euch die Arena-Website nur ans Herz legen.
Dort findet ihr viele, viele Antworten rund ums Thema.
Und ansonsten, wenn ihr noch andere Fragen habt, zögert nicht unten in den Kommentaren was zu schreiben. Ich antworte euch da gerne.
Ansonsten, vielen Dank für's Zuschauen, und bleibt neugierig! Euer Cedric.